une autre étape pour le secrétaire
d'État américain il est arrivé en Israël
après un premier arrêt en Égypte
l'objectif de ces tourner tenter
d'éloigner le spectre de la violence
c'est la responsabilité de tout le monde
de calmer les tensions au lieu de les
nourrir dit-il
désamorcer une situation de crise qui se
profile
après un raid israélien la semaine
dernière en six jours Dany le plus
meurtrier depuis des années suivi de tir
de roquette depuis la bande de Gaza et
l'attentat près d'une synagogue à
Jérusalem l'administration américaine a
exprimé sa position
les Palestiniens et les Israéliens
bénéficiant des mêmes droits à la
liberté et la sécurité et la justice et
la dignité
veulent essayer de d'arbitrer un peu des
deux côtés mais ont des moyens de
pression en bout de ligne limité sur
certains éléments dans la coalition puis
du côté palestinien les États-Unis ont
aussi des une influence limitée parce
que les Palestiniens la l'autorité
Palestine elle-même a perdu beaucoup de
crédibilité un défi pour les Américains
qui doivent composer avec un
gouvernement israélien le plus à droite
de l'histoire du pays avec des ultra
conservateurs et des gens qui appellent
pratiquement à l'annexion des l'histoire
occupé et au transfert ou à certaines
changements démographiques des
territoires où les Palestiniens résides
l'Iran était aussi au cœur des
discussions
notre politique ma politique est de tout
faire pour empêcher l'Iran de développer
des armes nucléaires
si jamais il tient comme il le dit
clairement que son souci premier c'est
la bombe nucléaire en Iran alors il n'a
pas le choix que de s'allier à la vision
américaine et les alliés arabes des
Américains parce que Washington veut
consolider les accords d'Abraham
incluant les Émirats et le Bahreïn et
même les élargir à d'autres pays arabes
pour le moment l'urgence est à
l'apaisement le conflit
israélo-palestinien semble renouer avec
ses heures les plus sombres ici Yasmine
Khayat Radio-Canada Montréal